[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire complotisme fait news
manipulation des informations peu de
vérité vérité alternative vérité
officielle
comment en est on arrivé là le mensonge
a toujours existé en politique mais
aujourd'hui s'est installé au coeur de
la vie publique
pourquoi comment c'est ce c'est le sujet
du nouveau livre d'anne cécile robert
dernières nouvelles du mensonge qui
vient de paraître chez lux édition va en
parler pendant toute cette émission et
l'on commence comme d'habitude par une
image que celle que notre invitée elle
choisi pour illustrer ce début de xxième
siècle cécile robert alors qu'est ce que
ça représente
et pourquoi cette image ça ça représente
des chaînes d'esclaves et c'est un
monument qui se trouve à paris et qui a
été érigée en 2008 en hommage au général
dumas le père d'alexandre dumas
il existait auparavant une statue qui a
été fondue par les allemands pendant la
guerre et qui représentait le général
dumas en grand uniforme général dumas
est un héros de la révolution française
qui a combattu à la tête des troupes
françaises et qui s'est illustré en
s'opposant à bonaparte et quand il s'est
agi de reconstruire un monument à son
honneur un appel d'offres a été lancé
par la mairie de paris et la mairie de
paris a choisi comme symbole du général
dumas de ses chaînes d'esclaves
pourquoi parce que effectivement le
général dumas est un ancien esclave
affranchi et ils ont préféré la mairie
de paris a préféré ce symbole a par
exemple le projet de du sculpteur
sénégalais ousmane sow qui proposait de
représenter le général dumas en grand
uniforme de la révolution française en
train de dompter un
un cheval est donc il m'a semblé assez
en symbolique de notre société
ce choix de représenter un héros de la
révolution française par des chaînes
d'esclaves comme si l'expérience de
victimes qui est celle du général était
supérieur à ses qualités de héros il me
semble qu'il ya quelque chose d'assez
symbolique d'une certaine ambiance
sociale aujourd'hui qui fait qu'on va
choisir des emblèmes qui nous rapproche
plus des victimes que des héros alors
pour être tout à fait honnête sur sur ce
dossier c'est la société des amis
d'alexandre dumas en la personne d'andré
bellon qui a révélé la sphère en 2008
et l'histoire se termine plutôt bien
puisque la cia quelques semaines la
mairie de paris a décidé de réparer son
erreur et de diriger une nouvelle statue
du général dumas en pied dans son
uniforme de général de la révolution
probablement ils vont probablement la
mettre à côté mais vont pas enlever les
chaînes d'esclaves ils vont simplement
faire coexister les deux les deux les
deux emblèmes
mais est-ce que ça n'est pas
effectivement la meilleure solution
parce que de le montrer en grand général
dont temps un cheval donc en héros
est-ce que ça n'est pas faire
abstraction est-ce que ça n'est pas
faire disparaître son passé d'esclaves
justement c'est une vraie question mais
est-ce que se passait d'esclaves est
aussi important que ça c'est à dire
l'esclavagé est une question
fondamentale et surtout qui a
aujourd'hui des millions d'esclaves dans
le monde
donc il faut effectivement à chaque fois
rappelé cette expérience de l' esclavage
et de la traite transatlantique en même
temps est ce que cette expérience là
doit effacer
d'autres expériences je trouve que le
symbole d'un homme sorti du rang qui est
qui est sorti justement de cette
expérience de l' esclavage et qui a fait
une carrière brillante dans un événement
majeur qu'est la révolution française
qui a été héroïque à risquer sa vie qui
a eu le courage de s'opposer à bonaparte
est à mon avis plus
édifiant pour les jeunes générations
comment faisait dans le temps c'est
beaucoup plus édifiant pour les jeunes
que de que de ramener ce héros à une
condition plus qu'il n'a pas choisi il a
été à franchir il s'est pas évadé il a
été a franchi la question s'est posée
aux états unis de la même manière quand
on a fait on a érigé une statue de
franklin roosevelt sur son fauteuil
roulant
et alors qu'on a dit mais pendant toute
son existence pas l'existence qu'il a
passé sur son fauteuil roulant
justement il a toujours voulu le cacher
et apparaître toujours debout ou que
l'on puisse croire qu'il était debout et
donc c'était le le haut font aller
contre sa volonté que de le représenter
en fauteuil roulant et en même temps de
ne pas savoir que franklin roosevelt se
déplacer en fauteuil roulant d'une
certaine manière c'est oblitéré une
partie de la vérité mais changeons de
sujet revenons-en aux vérités et au
mensonge
commençons
[Musique]
anne cécile robert vous êtes journaliste
au monde diplomatique et professeur
associé à l'université paris 8 vous êtes
l'auteur de la stratégie de l'émotion
chez lux je vous avais reçu d'ailleurs
dans cette émission
quand le livre est sorti est aujourd'hui
toujours chez lux vous publiez dernières
nouvelles du mensonge vous expliquer
qu'on ne peut pas comprendre le
phénomène des fêtes news ou du
complotisme sans analyser d'abord les
vérités officielles qui ont envahi la
parole politique à partir des années 80
90 et qui ont propagé dans nos
démocraties des vision dogmatique
l'un ne va pas sans l'autre le
complotisme l'effet que news ça ne va
pas sans les vérités officielles les
dogmes qui se sont propagés à l'époque
c'est un peu une facilité effectivement
que de dénoncer les faits que news le
complotisme c'est extrêmement facile en
plus ceux qui les portent sont parfois
des vrais caricature quand on pense à à
donald trump
on a des épouvantails et des repoussoirs
facile mais ce faisant on évite de se
poser la question pourquoi étant donné
qu'il ya toujours eu des mensonges dans
l'histoire et dans les sociétés pourquoi
est-ce que ses mensonges ont pris une
telle importance aujourd'hui
et s'ils ont pris une telle importance
aujourd'hui c'est pas tellement parce
qu'il ya des instruments pour les
propager comme les réseaux sociaux c'est
parce que nos sociétés sont devenues
perméable aux mensonges et qu'elles ont
brouillé les frontières de la vérité et
du mensonge
en réhabilitant par exemple des vérités
officielles ou des mensonges officiels
qui en fait sont acclimatées une
certaine soumission à des vérités
révélées qui
empêche vous prive ou décrédibilise ce
qui doit être important dans les
sociétés démocratiques
c'est à dire l'esprit critique alors les
mensonges la vérité c'est vraiment un
vieux très vieux débat d'ailleurs pour
illustrer cette émission j'ai demandé à
ce qu'on on montre des couvertures de
livres qui traitent de ces sujets là de
tout temps alors ya de bons comme de
mauvais livres la plupart je les ai pas
lues d'ailleurs mais mais on s'aperçoit
que c'est un très vieux sujet d'où le
titre de votre livre dernières nouvelles
du mensonge
comme quoi vous vous situez dans une
tradition mais avant de parler du
mensonge parlant de ce que c'est que la
vérité officielle la vérité officielle
pour nous c'est la marque des dictatures
et même pire c'est la marque des
systèmes totalitaires
on estime que dans des démocraties comme
la nôtre il ne peut pas y avoir de
vérité officielle puisque le débat est
libre est ce qu'il est ce que comment se
fait-il que d'après vous la vérité
officielle fait son retour dans nos
démocraties en particulier en france à
partir des années 80 90 qu'à partir de
quand quel moment est ce qu'on peut
parler de vérité officielle
vu que toutes ces vérités officielles
ont lu des contestataires
les vérités officielles n'ont
effectivement pas leur place dans les
démocraties on est plus habitué à les
trouver dans des régimes autoritaires ou
dans les dictatures et ce qui s'est
passé c'est que à partir des années 80
avec la montée en puissance de la
mondialisation libérale
la disparition progressive des formes
d'opposition que pouvaient constituer
des les régimes communistes ou
soviétique
on est entré dans le fantasme d'une
sorte de fin de l'histoire qu'avec
beaucoup été commenté à l'époque et qui
avait un corollaire qu'on a peut-être
moins remarquée et si c'est la fin de
l'histoire
finalement c'est aussi la fin du débat
parce que l'histoire étant un mouvement
implique la contradiction implique
l'opposition
des points de vue implique des querelles
sur les faits et leur interprétation et
à partir des années 80 n'a voulu tuer
tout ça en estimant que la société
libérale mondialisée était la société
achevée qui mettait un terme à
finalement tous les questionnements
humains depuis des siècles ou des
millénaires sur qu'est ce que c'est que
le bonheur la liberté qu'est ce que
c'est qu'une qu'une vie bonne et on a vu
s'installer des vérités officielles
comme je pense à margaret thatcher il
n'y a qu'une seule politique économique
possible
hier la société n'existe pas la
construction européenne aussi a été
pendant un moment le théâtre de deux
vérités officielles
c'était cette europe là où et pas une
autre
et de ce fait on a rétrécit l'espace du
débat et ce qui est parfois de manière
très violente je pense à la construction
européenne avec des personnalités comme
comme jean marie cavada ou jacques
delors qui disait ce qui compte est
celui ci c'est le traité constitutionnel
européen le traité de maastricht devrait
arrêter de faire de la politique ou jean
marie cavada 10 ans ce qui compte est ce
le traité constitutionnel européen
devrait penser à auschwitz là c'est une
façon de clore le débat d'une manière un
peu spectaculaire et ça malheureusement
ça vient des médias ça vient de la
classe politique démocratique et et
pourtant c'est le contraire de la
liberté puisque ces dépenses est imposée
alors dans le cas de jean marie cavada
effectivement c'était dire devrait
penser à auschwitz et que l'un des
arguments de la construction européenne
c'est pour que jamais plus les deux
guerres en europe et que la dernière
avait mené à auschwitz d'où le doubs ce
chantage moral qui pouvait s'effectuer
qui s'effectuent encore parfois
d'ailleurs en ce qui concerne l'europe
est-ce que ce que vous ce dont vous
parlez
l'instauration de vérité officielle à
part ces années 80-90 qu est ce que ça
n'est pas faux substantielle au fait que
l'économie à partir de ce moment là
s'est vengé de la politique
en fait jusque là on pouvait faire de la
politique le général de gaulle disait
l'intendance suivra
et puis là partir de ce moment là on dit
non c'est pas la tendance qui suivent
c'est le contraire c'est la politique
doit s'adapter avec à l'économie qui
elle nous parle de la réalité mais le
tout ceux qui ont étudié l'idéologie je
pense à claude lefort savent bien que le
l'un des traits caractéristiques de
l'idéologie 7 se prendre pour la réalité
est là on entend dans la volonté de
sortir l'économie du débat politique a
quelque chose de profondément
idéologique comme si l'économie était
une science exacte une une vérité
constaté indiscutable alors que on a des
exemples y compris dans l'actualité
je pense au débat sur la dette la dette
est une réalité on la voit la dette
qu'ovide tout le monde l'a constaté
et pourtant vous avez des économistes
bardé de diplômes qui s'affrontent sur
comment expliquer cette dette comment
l'analyser et comment faut-il annuler
par un nul et c'est donc le l'économie
c'est quelque chose de forcément
politique et la prétention à ne pas la
discuter d'une prétention très
idéologique qui consistait à imposer une
vision économique libérale libre
échangiste au détriment j'allais dire
même pas des visions socialistes ou
communistes on n'était même plus là les
mêmes des visions keynésienne
c'est à dire qui accorde un rôle
important à l'état dans l'économie qui
prévoit par exemple des nationalisations
où l'industrie puisqu'on en parle
beaucoup aujourd'hui donc on est rentré
dans un cycle de méconnaissance
idéologique de l'idéologie comme disait
claude lefort est-ce que ça des proc pas
propre à tout pouvoir est ce que tout
pouvoir ne tente pas par tous les moyens
d'instaurer des vérités officielles des
vérités indiscutables qu'on puisse plus
débattre à perte de vue de choses qui
lui paraissent d'ores et déjà réglé ou
tout simplement parce qu'il veut
convaincre les électeurs qu'il a raison
parfois on impose des vérités
officielles
tout simplement pour que pour que les
électeurs soient convaincus que ça va
mieux ou ou au contraire que ça va moins
bien
le il ya tout un discours sur la
violence par exemple comme quoi il y
aurait une recrudescence de la violence
kit est instauré à partir des années 90
qui droite pousse à peu près sur aucun
fait c'est à dire que la société
française étaient plus violentes
il ya 50 ans qu'aujourd'hui mais on est
tous persuadés que celle inverse et
personne ne revient dessus et moi-même
là quand je le dis je suis sûr qu'il ya
des gens qui nous écoutent qui disent
comment est ce qu'il peut dire à tous
pareils vous voyez et c'est comme ça
le pouvoir est une des choses les moins
penser je trouve du monde michel
foucault avait écrit des choses très
intéressantes
là-dessus entre autres je suis très
frappé de voir à quel point par exemple
la gauche qui prétend conquérir le
pouvoir au service de vision
progressiste transformatrice de la
société pratique le pouvoir de la même
manière que la droite et même ceux qui
aujourd'hui prétendent être les plus
révolutionnaires possible finalement se
retrouve avec le culte du chef des
visions unilatérales des visions
finalement très personnelle du pouvoir
or on pourrait très bien
imaginez une vision plus collective du
pouvoir une vision plus interrogative du
pouvoir plus plus partagés moins
unilatéral qui ferait place précisément
au débat et à la contradiction
le débat relève à mon sens des principes
de précaution parce que personne n'a la
science infuse personne ne peut
prétendre détenir la vérité et tout
comprendre de tous c'est à dire pour
pour plaisanter on pourrait dire que
même jésus a eu des doutes dans le
désert et certains hommes ou femmes
politiques aujourd'hui ont l'air heureux
de faire comme s'il pouvait découvrir
tout ça voire même du monde
en fait la vérité ne peut être qu'une
construction sociale ne peut être que le
produit de la confrontation des points
de vue c'est pour ça que je dis que le
débat et relève du principe de
précaution parce que c'est la seule
façon finalement d'arriver à faire
émerger un petit peu de vérité parce
qu'on a tous les angles de vue tous les
points de vue et c'est justement leur
confrontation leur mise en débat qui va
permettre à la société de se faire une
idée et c'est ça qui manque aujourd'hui
on peut on pourrait dire que au fond il
ya eu une époque où dans la vie
démocratique française
il y avait des oppositions et des
contestations qui était acceptée est
entendu en même temps parmi ces
contestations il y avait par exemple la
contestation communiste qui était très
importante parti communiste avait
beaucoup d'électeurs mais qui en même
temps sur un certain nombre de sujets
reposer sur des mensonges qui étaient
les mensonges de l'union soviétique
effectivement un moment c'est comme si
on avait dit bon ben maintenant on
arrête avec avec les mensonges on va
plus parler contre gens qui connaissent
la vérité et par la même occasion plein
d'intellectuels plein de
plein de contestataires se sont
retrouvés réduits au silence et ça se
passe c'est effectivement dans les
années 80 90 à partir du moment où il ya
une forme de consensus qui s'établit sur
un certain nombre de valeurs sur un
certain nombre de discours la réalité
comme ça et pas autrement
et à partir de quoi on va procéder à des
excommunications mais pas seulement sur
l'économie sur la guerre en
ex-yougoslavie sur le kosovo sur sur la
violence sur sur le terrorisme surtout
en fait on a construit peut
progressivement d'aidé société obsédée
par le consensus
françois mitterrand en parlait beaucoup
le consensus est devenu une valeur en
soi
alors je ne suis pas opposé au consensus
en tant que tel jeu je m'inquiète du
consensus a priori et c'est ça le
problème aujourd'hui c'est que le
consensus devient le point de départ
alors que dans une démocratie sauf à
considérer que que la vérité est quelque
chose de prêts existants comme une
espèce de trésor caché qu'il faudrait
trouver le consensus ne peut être qu'un
aboutissement de de quelque chose la
pathologie de nos sociétés qui est
peut-être lié à des formes de peur on
était en des sociétés qui ont peur c'est
de vouloir se rassurer en évitant toute
forme de conflit
toute forme de conflit y compris le
moindre dissensus là le moindre
dissensus devient perturbateurs devient
inquiétant comme s'ils pouvaient
dégénérer et vous disiez tout à l'heure
je faisais allusion à la vie politique
et à 50 ans ou si on remonte à la 3ème
république la vie politique était
beaucoup plus violente qu aujourd'hui et
je parle pas des attentats anarchistes
je parle des gestions ce qui avait par
exemple à l'assemblée nationale on se
traitait de deux noms d'oiseaux où on
s'insultait copieusement parfois même
grande époque ça se terminait dans les
fossés de vincennes ou régler ça à part
un duel à l'épée je crois que le dernier
lieu dans les années 1950 aujourd'hui un
petit nom de l'oiseau peut vous
entraîner devant un tribunal pour pour
insulte pour on s'offusque que de la
moindre chose ce qui assez petit le
débat fait que les hommes et les femmes
politiques se retiennent ont peur on le
sent bien de parler de peur que un mot
de travers
nantes rennes reçoit une polémique sur
les réseaux sociaux soit carrément une
attaque en diffamation
or il n'y a pas de vie politique a pas
de vie sociale n'y a pas de vie
démocratique
si on ne débat pas sans peur sans
crainte
et si on n'a pas peur de l' échange
d'arguments
alors quand évidemment ce sont des des
échanges
d'arguments s'il s'agit tout simplement
de ce traité d'abruti ou d'un poster
évidemment c'est pas très intéressant
mais il peut pas y avoir de vie
intellectuelle de vie tout court
s'il n'y a pas un minimum de 10 insu
s'il n'y a pas un minimum de doute
1 c'est ça aussi qui manque aujourd'hui
il peut pas y avoir de vie politique
sans sens un peu de doutes qui permet
justement d'écouter les arguments de
l'autre si vous êtes convaincu c'est
michel rocard qu'avait créé un club
s'appelait convaincre ça m'a toujours
choqué c'est si vous voulez convaincre
les autres vous êtes convaincu d j'avoue
même d'avoir raison
donc la possibilité de dialogue est
limité donc faut toujours garder une
part une part de doute pour que le
l'espace de discussion puisse
puis s'installer sinon on a au mieux un
affrontement de vérité au pire une chape
de plomb avec une vérité qui s'impose
qui s'impose à tout le monde mais il
yal'idée s'ils tentaient qu'il ya
effectivement une idéologie qu elle soit
invisible ou dominante une pensée unique
selon lui a donné plusieurs noms à 7
on l'appelle aussi le néolibéralisme
d'ailleurs tous ceux qui s'y opposent
il est entendu qu'au fond c'est parce
qu'il ils n'ont pas compris
et d'ailleurs le gouvernement très
souvent parle d'un défaut de
communication
et au fond je me demande si dans la
période que vous étudiez dans ce livre
on n'a pas sacraliser l'économie et la
communication au détriment de la
politique
si les gens ne sont pas d'accord s'il se
révoltent s'ils manifestent c'est qu'ils
ont leur a pas bien expliqué alors soit
parce qu'ils sont trop bêtes soit parce
qu'on leur a trouvé pas bien expliqué et
donc c'est toujours à défaut de
communication
il n'est pas entendu qu'on puisse être
d'un avis contraire ou même qu'on puisse
que l'opposition puisse avoir raison
la communication c'est effectivement au
point où on en est arrivé là la mort de
la politique parce que au lieu de
d'expliquer et de présenter une idée une
opinion une politique en la soumettant à
la critique ce qui est normalement le
béa bad de la vie démocratique
on va chercher à imposer son point de
vue par des outils de communication les
fameux éléments de
de langage et on sent bien le pouvoir
actuel de incarné par emmanuel macron
est vraiment le symbole de cette
domination de la communication à chaque
problème ce gouvernement répond par un
exercice de communication on donne des
interviews ont construit des éléments de
langage
or je cite emmanuel macron mais il est
l'emblème d'un phénomène le plus profond
qui atteint la gauche comme la droite
tous les tous les mouvements politiques
sont dans cette dans cette volonté de
faire passer leur message
c'est ça c'est faire passer un message
au lieu de défendre un point de vue sur
dans un espace public avec effectivement
le risque d'avoir à se remettre en cause
alors il ya peut-être aussi dans tout ça
un produit de nos sociétés narcissique
où on a peur justement de se remettre en
cause ou où on a l'impression que quand
une idée qu'on défend et combattu bas
c'est nous-mêmes qui sommes qui sommes
combattus alors que l'on peut avoir tort
à m'en donner raison à un autre à un
autre moment
et cette obsession de la communication
c'est la mort de la politique c'est la
mort de la vie
démocratique parce que à ce jeu là
finalement ce n'est qu'une question de
moyens et ceux qui ont plus que de
moyens que les autres peuvent imposer
leur point de vue mais au fond on ne
débat jamais de rien dans une société de
communication on envoie des messages
mais on ne discute de rien ce qui fait
que on contribue finalement à fragmenter
la société alors on crée des sociétés
parallèles qui ne sont plus capables de
discuter
c'est peut-être le problème fondamental
de nos sociétés d'aujourd'hui c'est de
favoriser le mensonge par cette hyper
fragmentation qui fait que chacun va
courir dans son couloir sans sans
chercher à se confronter au point de vue
de l'autre et même à la réalité sociale
elle même et tout ça est mortifère et ne
peut finalement que susciter des
réactions
c'est en ce sens que j'interprète le
populisme ou même le phénomène d'été feq
news ce sont aussi des pathologies en
réaction de façade et démocratie qui ne
sont plus que des théâtres ou où les
chances d'idées
et quasiment impossible sauf sur le sur
le terrain de l'invectivé ou du combat
de communicants comme on dit maintenant
un coup de slogans et d'éléments de
langage
en fait c'est comment en est on arrivé à
tout un gouvernement pendant le premier
confinement il ya un an
nous expliquons qu'il n'y a pas de
problème de masse qu'en france il n'y a
pas de pénurie de masques
c'est ce que tout le monde nous a répété
d'ailleurs les masques n'ont aucune
utilité donc il peut pas y avoir un
problème et il peut pas y avoir de
pénurie mais aussi à linverse c'est
toute une frange de la population et pas
seulement en france qui l a décrété
qu'il n'y avait pas de virus il n'y
avait pas d'épidémie tout ça était une
invention un mensonge alors comment on
est arrivé à ces deux
assez de mensonges qui ce qu'ils se
confrontent
c'est ce qu'on va voir juste après une
pause
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours avec anne cécile
robert qui publie dernières nouvelles du
mensonge
on a on a bien vu comment d'après vous
toutes ces vérités officielles sur à peu
près tous les sujets ont construit un
nouveau régime du mensonge dites vous
dans un univers dogmatique au fond la
vérité de viale mensonges et c'est à
partir de là que va se construire un
contre-discours on va commencer à
observer qu'il ya un décalage entre ce
que nous disent nos dirigeants nos
intellectuels nos savants et puis la
réalité sociale qu'on constate autour de
soi et à tort ou à raison on va se
révolter et ça va donner ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui le populisme et qui
commence en france avec la montée de
l'extrême droite mais en italie avec
l'arrivée au pouvoir de berlusconi etc
etc
le mot populisme
c'est s'est répandue il faudrait
peut-être s'interroger un peu plus
souvent sur son véritable sens parce
qu'on on a tendance à l'identifier à
démagogie le populisme n'est pas
forcément de la démagogie et ça peut en
être effectivement c'est à dire la
volonté de manipuler les masses de
flatter les populations pour parvenir au
pouvoir ou pour pour se maintenir mais
le populisme n'est pas forcément de
de la démagogie ça peut aussi être il ya
eu des courants de pensée qui l'ont bien
que non qu'ils ont bien étudié cela peut
aussi être une façon d'écouter les
revendications populaires de d'écouter
les souhaits des catégories sociales les
plus faibles parce que là l'une des
caractéristiques aussi des vérités
officielles qui se sont imposés dans la
période récente
c'est de coïncider avec un ordre social
qui est un ordre social inégalitaire
l'ordre néolibéral qui s'accommode d'
inégalités grandissantes des inégalités
sociales grandissantes d'un chômage de
masse et donc la vérité officielle il
n'y a qu'une seule politique économique
possible une seule robe possible et
c'est sa compagne de la justification
d'un ordre économique qui fait souffrir
de plus en plus de gens qui ne trouvent
pas de travail ou qui y voient leurs
droits sociaux réduit de jour en jour et
c'est en ce sens que la démocratie
moderne post années 80 à décrédibiliser
la vérité en installant des vérités
officielles qui sont des vérités
antisociale et qui sont aussi les gens
étaient parfaitement docile ou avait
envie de mourir en silence ne peut que
conduire à des révoltes les gens c'est
un petit peu comme ça que j'interprète
le mouvement des des gilets jaunes ça
qu'à un moment donné la réalité sociale
est tellement dur que il faut se
il faut réagir quitte à ce que ce soit
un peu désordonné ou violent et
malheureusement ces mouvements de
riposte aux vérités officielles ton dans
certains travers très néfaste le
complotisme la façon de nier des
réalités qui sont qui sont patentes ou
le fait de suivre des démagogues plus ou
moins talentueux
effectivement c'est c'est triste de voir
que la volonté de réagir contre des
vérités officielles conduit à d'autres
pathologies qui ne font pas avancer le
schmilblick hommes comme disait l'autre
mais nous nous maintient dans un théâtre
d'ombrés le l'erreur face à cette
situation et malheureusement celle qui
est souvent commises par les médias
dominants ou et partis politiques
dominants c'est de se contenter de
dénoncer le complotisme contenter de
dénoncer les faits que nous comme si le
complotisme à effectuer ou c'était tombé
du ciel comme ça les gens étaient
devenus fous ou alors plus grave que ça
les gens de toute façon sont un peu
idiot donc un petit un petit peu un
mépris de mépris de classe derrière tout
ça donc ils sont prêts ils sont
susceptibles de céder à n'importe quel
discours même le plus crétin et donc on
dénonce on dénonce
et puis phase d'après on se prémunit
c'est à dire on flic la société on ferme
autoritairement des comptes twitter on
on intervient de manière autoritaire
pour interdire certains langages sans
s'interroger sur la mécanique qui qui
fait que les gens ont eu malheureusement
la tentation de se réfugier dans le
complotisme et aussi pourquoi peut-être
encore plus
plus profondément pourquoi est ce que
les gens dans un dans un certain nombre
de situations ne sont plus capables de
distinguer la vérité du mensonge parce
que c'est ça aussi si les gens entre
guillemets les gens c'est une formule
toujours un peu un peu bizarre croix des
des thèses farfelues langues sur le 11
septembre ça devrait nous interroger
quand même
les gens sont pas tout d'un coup devenu
complètement idiot donc il faut essayer
de comprendre ce qui a conduit à ce que
les gens ne soient plus en situation de
distinguer la vérité du mensonge et j
insiste beaucoup dans le livre sur le
l'esprit critique est la faculté de
juger qu'il faut absolument réhabiliter
et qui a été à cause des vérités
officielles
battu en brèche moquer et il faut
réhabiliter l'esprit critique la liberté
de pensée et la faculté de juger comme
on disait dans le temps mais on ne peut
dissocier d'après ce que vous dites dans
votre livre au fond les théories du
complot sur le 11 septembre sont
indissociables du mensonge sur les armes
de destruction massive qui est porté par
le le gouvernement américain quand ils
décident d'envahir l'irak sans qui aucun
rapport entre l'irak et les attentats du
11 septembre
donc on va comme ça construire des
mensonges qui vont aller jusqu'à colline
powell avec sa fiole
et qui est le mensonge suprême auquel
collabore non seulement le gouvernement
américain mais le gouvernement
britannique
les journaux ou des états unis alors il
ya ceux qui sont trompés et puis il ya
ceux qui savent que c'est à ce mensonge
mais même ceux qui savent qu'ils
souhaitent que c'est un mensonge
le fonds peut être de bonne foi c'est
peut-être le cas de pauline powell il se
dit oui il ya sûrement des armes de
destruction massive alors le fait
d'avoir ma petite fiole c'est pas si
grave que ça au fond pour vous tout ça
est un bloc il y aurait pas de le succès
des théories du complot et du
complotisme qui construit concerne le 11
septembre ne peut se comprendre qu'à la
lumière de cet événement là les
démocrates ont eux-mêmes décrédibiliser
la vérité et il faut se souvenir quand
même de la violence de la riposte de
l'administration bush contre jacques
chirac
ils ont utilisé tous les moyens de
pression jusqu'à 1 changer le nom des
french fries s'effrite en liberty phrase
jacques chirac a subi des pressions des
coups de fil
on se souvient de françois hollande et
d'autres allant quasiment battre leur
coulpe devant l'ambassade des états unis
pour dire qu'il s'est excusé du
comportement de jacques chirac dont il
ya eu quelque chose d'extrêmement
violent qui était de la part de gens qui
sont supposés et qui continue de donner
des leçons aujourd'hui quand même il
faut se le rappeler qui était supposé
incarner la version moderne avancée du
progrès de la pensée de la liberté
notamment les sociaux-démocrates 1 qui
avait vaincu l'hydre communiste le
mensonge soviétique
on attendait on aurait pu quand même
attendre d'eux une forme de respect plus
sérieux plus pointilleux pour pour la
vérité et bien non tous ces gens ont
marché dans des vérités officielles et
ils ont contribué à construire le
problème qui à mon avis majeur
aujourd'hui c'est que nos sociétés
démocratiques sont devenus
structurellement mensongères elles sont
devenues structurellement mensongère
c'est à dire qu'elles ne sont plus
capables de produire de la vérité au
sens où il peut pas y avoir de vérité
s'il ya pas de l'espace public des
espaces social de confrontation des
points de vue et nos sociétés
aujourd'hui sont tellement fragmenté
tellement atomisé tellement habitués à
la bataille de la communication
tellement habitué aux logiques de
soumission qu'induisent les vérités
officielles que l ce sont des habitués
aux 10 insu ce créateur à l'affrontement
au débat libre et raisonnée disait notre
ami condorcet et c'est de ça qu'il faut
sortir et ça ça implique que les
démocrates face lors jeudi lesdemocrates
au sens général du terme pas les
démocrates américains fassent un peu
leur introspection et réhabilite le
doute des cartes le père du rationalisme
à fonder toute sa méthode sûre sur le
doute on oublie tout le temps ça on a
l'impression que le rationalisme c'est
un truc froid comme ça qu'ils qui
consiste à additionner ou ou à regarder
des chaînes causalement il ya un doute
méthodique au départ donc il faut qu'on
renoue avec le doute méthodique de notre
de descartes sans avoir peur et puis
avoir suffisamment de respect pour
l'adversaire ou celui qui ne pense pas
comme nous pour l'écouté vraiment kita
effectivement à mettre la possibilité
que on n'a peut-être pas complet
mon raison mais c'est vrai que le débat
c'est plus dur que le combat s'est assis
le combat vous arrivez vous mettez votre
armure et vous cogner le débat c'est un
pic de pause et d'armures et d'accepter
deux éventuellement de prendre des
arguments dans la figure auquel on
n'avait pas pensé
et puis de se dire ah oui là peut-être
peut-être que j'ai exagéré ou peut-être
que je me trompe et cnra il faut un peu
de modestie un peu de force aussi
anne cécile robert aujourd'hui on
pourrait dire que l'idéologie
néolibérale on va l'appeler comme ça
elle est dénoncée toutes parts elle est
dénoncée par les souverainistes elle est
dénoncée par les protectionnistes elle
est dénoncée par les écologistes est les
décombres elle est dénoncée par les
nationalistes par les communistes
j'ai impressionné alors depuis le la
griffe du grenelle virus on a
l'impression qu'elle est qu'elle est en
lambeaux
les les vérités officielles dont vous
parlez ne tiennent plus qu'à un fil non
je crois que c'est ce qui peut nous
rendre optimiste finalement c'est le
destin des vérités officielles que
d'être à un moment donné renversé parce
qu'une vérité officielle c'est comme un
char d'assaut c'est comme un bunker
ça tient le temps que l'infrastructure
est solide mais il ya toujours un moment
où quelqu'un fait sauter le char ou
quelqu'un mais une grenade dans le
bunker
ça c'est plutôt rassurant ça veut dire
que sur le long terme les soviétiques en
ont fait l'expérience
la vie reprend le dessus la volonté de
débattre le j'allais dire l'instinct de
liberté des êtres humains refait surface
et toutes les vérités officielles
finissent par être renversé donc là le
néolibéralisme subi ce sort aujourd'hui
et il est contesté et critiqué de toute
part pas forcément toujours avec
beaucoup d'intelligence
c'est le problème des vérités
officielles qu'avec un moment donné on
est tellement contents de les renverser
qu'on se permet des arguments
caricaturaux ou qu'on risque de verser
soi-même dans dans une autre vérité
officielle et ce qui n'apparaît pas
toujours pas aujourd'hui à mon avis est
ce qui est toujours malheureusement
critiqué et déprécier contrairement à ce
qu'on pourrait penser c'est la
démocratie la démocratie au sens des
espaces publics libre et raisonnée ou
les êtres humains peuvent par la
confrontation des points de vue
construire l'intérêt général cette idée
là est de plus en plus minoritaire
aujourd'hui l'idée que l'être humain
puisse par sa raison et aussi en
employant son son coeur construire
fraternellement avec les autres un
espace de discussion imaginé un autre
présent et se projeter dans le futur
cette idée là et
de plus en plus critique est battue en
brèche
j'interprète comme ça par exemple même
si ça nous sort un peu du nôtre sujet le
tirage au sort
nouvelle mode depuis quelques temps
c'est au lieu de voter
on va tirer au sort des panel
d'individus qu'on va appeler citoyens
mais qui en fait ne sont là que parce
que le sort les a désignés et qui sont
censées une fois qu'on les a enfermés
dans une petite boîte faire émerger la
vérité une espèce de graal qu'ils
auraient cherché ensemble lors c'est le
cas typique de la convention climat avec
évidemment cette absurdité que ils
aboutissent à des vérités qui sont
forcément partiels qui ne sont pas
représentatives de la réalité sociale
puisqu'il n'y a pas eu de véritable
débat autre que la main du sort et qui
ensuite sont manipulés par par le
gouvernement et c'est en fait
emblématique de de vision complètement
régressive et primitive si j'ose dire de
la vérité la conception la vérité qui
domine aujourd'hui c'est la conception
de la vérité comme un trésor caché
il faut chercher la vérité voilà alors
que la vérité c'est une construction et
c'est forcément une construction sociale
c'est-à-dire qui implique le maximum de
points de vue divergent et il n'y a pas
de vérité a priori ce que je reproche
aux partisans du tirage au sort et au
parti jean des conventions des
conférences citoyennes c'est de partir
de l'idée qu'il ya une vérité à
découvrir et que on va trouver une
vérité objective
ça ça me paraît une idée fausse parce
que à partir des mêmes faits on peut
regarder le débat par exemple si on
reste sur le climat sur les éoliennes à
partir du même constat c'est à dire
qu'il faut lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique et qu'il faut
trouver des énergies alternatives
vous avez des gens qui pensent que les
éoliennes sont une solution intéressante
d'autres qui pensent que ça fait plus de
mal que de bien mais tant qu'on n'a pas
un espace public
de débat là dessus on va avoir des gens
qui s'affrontent avec des gens qui
impose des éoliennes dans des coins
pendant que d'autres font des tracts et
des manifs pour lutter contre les
éoliennes
donc c est ça c'est parce qu'on n'arrive
pas à penser le climat communes comme
quelque chose de demain problèmes
politiques sociales et qu'on a peur
d'eux si on met en discussion la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique on va
laisser la place aux climato sceptiques
alors je comprends bien il faut pas
mais du coup on aboutit à une espèce de
vérité climatique qui va susciter des
chocs en retour et je trouve assez
emblématique le la polémique sur les sur
les éoliennes par exemple au fond on dit
toujours qu'on est à une époque de
scepticisme généralisé mais en fait la
plupart des gens sont très peu ces
petits qui n'ont pas beaucoup de doute
simplement ils choisissent une vérité
plutôt qu'une autre on voit s'affronter
dans dans un cas où il ya une
coexistence de diffuser vers it est
différente parfois même où poser qui
s'affrontent c'est un pur rapport de
force entre autres des vérités
différentes comme pendant la guerre
froide au fond où il y avait la vérité
du monde libre enfin entre guillemets
qui se considérait comme le mon niveau
et puis les vérités qui avait lieu qui
circulait dans le monde communiste qui
n'était pas du tout les mêmes
j'imagine que pendant l' empire colonial
c'était la même chose il y avait une
vérité sur la colonisation contenait ton
métropole y en avait une autre qu'on
tenait dans l'est dans les pays
colonisés et puis j'imagine que si les
africains les vietnamiens les algériens
avaient pu twitté l époque on aurait eu
une autre vérité qui était celle du
colonisé ou des colonisés justement donc
j'en reviens quand même à la technologie
au fond
il ya toujours eu des vérités différente
aujourd'hui la différence c'est que tout
le monde est devenu émetteurs et que
autrefois vous écriviez une lettre au
journal pour vous plaindre mais ça
s'arrêtait là on mettait la lettre au
panier aujourd'hui vous êtes émetteurs
donc vous allez trouver des gens qui
sont d'accord avec vous et ça va comme
ça à faire florès est effectivement
aujourd'hui tout le monde peut mettre
son grain de sel dans le débat public
tout le monde peut y aller de son petit
message
tout le monde peut
proposez jeter son point de vue sur la
place publique
vous évoquez des rapports de force le
problème c'est que tout ça ne communique
pas c'est ça la difficulté d'aujourd'hui
c'est que d'un côté on a effectivement
des outils pour exprimer des choses avec
plus de facilité qui lie à 30 40 ou ou
50 ans mais en même temps ces vérités ne
communique pas et les réseaux sociaux
ça a été assez bien démontré par
certains sociologues crée des effets de
meute et au bout d'un moment les gens ne
communiquent plus qu'avec des gens qui
pensent comme eux et on a au mieux des
polémiques qui tourne à l'anathème qui
sont extrêmement caricaturale mais on a
très rarement de vraies discussions
d'abord c'est pas avec un tweet de 250
signe que vous allez pouvoir élaborer un
argumentaire c'est forcément même si
vous faites un fil
c'est quand même très très limité et
c'est en ce sens que moi je ne crois pas
aux as que les outils soient en
eux-mêmes mauvais les twitter facebook
instagram tout ça le soutien ne sont pas
en eux-mêmes mauvais ils sont ils sont
mauvais parce que derrière notre esprit
s'est atrophiée et qu'on a intégré nous
mêmes des logiques de meute des logiques
de combat plutôt que de débats des
logiques pour imposer notre point de vue
est que on esquive à chaque fois que
qu'on le peut la véritable confrontation
des points de vue si tous les gens je
suis dit n'importe quoi mais rêvons cinq
minutes
si tous les tous ceux qui sont derrière
leur compte twitter ou facebook avait
vraiment envie de discuter de manière
libre et raisonnée on aurait une autre
ambiance sur les réseaux sociaux on
aurait plus de questions que
d'affirmations on aurait on n'aurait pas
tous ces gens qui vous insulte sans vous
connaître qui on voit même pas des
arguments maintenant ils ont quoi des
gifs des petites images où on se moque
copieusement de vaud de vous où on fait
des procès d'intention et c'est ça qui
manque c'est cet esprit il faudrait
ravivé en fait la flamme du démocrate la
fram la flamme du rationaliste habité
par par le doute pour essayer de de
sortir de ces logiques de guerre
d'affrontements qui sont mortifères
parce que la logique de de ça là on
s'affronte sur les réseaux sociaux on
sait très bien
vous parliez de violence tout à l'heure
que la violence verbale peut passer à un
moment donné à la violence physique et
qu' abandonner la violence verbale ne
suffit pas on commence d'ailleurs à
avoir des désastres contenant on a vu
génération identitaire venir provoquer
des manifestants place de la république
et c'est la logique de ces affrontements
verbaux
c'est qu'à un moment donné est une forme
de passage à l'acte est donc et qui va
devenir physique
ici on ne désamorce pas la bombe en
réhabilitant déjà le temps long
aujourd'hui on est dans une espèce
d'urgence il faut absolument faire un
tweet en trois secondes donc on
réfléchit pas donc on réagit parfois
violemment bêtement sommairement alors
que si on avait pris mais ne serait-ce
qu'une demi heure on aurait peut-être
répondu avec de manière plus posée et
plus construite donc il faut qu'on
renoue avec le temps long prendre notre
temps là comme on le fait en ce moment
discuter tranquillement pour redonner de
l'espace à l'argumentaire prendre le
temps de poser des faits et de poser des
questions à m qu' on n'a pas la vérité
sur tout et que si on peut dire oui
mc c'est le robert parce qu'il nous
reste plus que trois minutes
la grande question quand même c est ce
que la vérité existe je veux dire que la
vérité scientifique exil
jusqu'à ce qu'elle droit soit remplacée
par une autre vérité scientifique qui
viendra se substitue elle mais la vérité
en tant que tel au fond on n'est plus
capable de séparer les faits de leur
interprétation et même sur un fait on
peut tous être d'accord pour dire que
tel fai s'est passé mais entre son
origine et ses conséquences
on va bien voir que personne n'est
d'accord avec personne surtout ça c'est
à dire qu'à un moment il ya deux les
interprétations sont tellement multiples
on se dit que les divas les divergences
sont telles qu'on ne s'entend plus sur
rien la vérité n'est pas quelque chose
d'absolu en fait elle existe mais c'est
pas quelque chose d'absolu c'est quelque
chose qui repose c'est quelque chose de
relatif au sens quelque chose qui nous
relient aux choses
ce qu'il ya des faits les faits existent
mais ils ne peuvent prendre leur sens
que si
on les confronte à d'autres faits et si
on les confronte à des points de vue
qu'on peut poser sur eux et en ce sens
il y à une méthodologie de la vérité
l'une des sources de la confusion
actuelle c'est que il ya plus de
méthodologie on va prendre un une
opinion pour une idée on va prendre une
impression pour un fait donc c'est la
question de la méthodologie ce qui fait
qu'on va distinguer et la méthode
scientifique ça dit bien ce que ça veut
dire
derrière j'observe je vérifie je
confronte j'éprouve et aujourd'hui c'est
tout le contraire qu'on fait on est dans
l'immédiateté
on croise con ce convoi on se fie à nos
impressions
donc il faut renouer avec une forme de
méthodologie et avec une force forme de
constructivisme sociale et politique qui
permet d'avancer dans la construction
d'une vérité sociale en admettant que
celle ci pourra être contestée et
qu'elle pourra évoluer au fur et à
mesure que les sociétés évoluent mais je
suis à la politique les politiques
qu'ils soient au pouvoir ou dans
l'opposition
eux ne connaissent qu'une chose depuis
l'origine des temps ça s'appelle la
propagande tout pouvoir fait de la
propagande et toute opposition fait de
la propagande aussi la propagande fait
partie du jeu mais on devrait être
capable de la deûle a repéré comme tel
le problème d'aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
confond propagande communication idée
débat en fait beaucoup de faux débat
entre des gens qui pensent la même chose
ou alors entre des gens qui sont
tellement opposées qui peut pas y avoir
de discussion et on devrait les citoyens
la société devrait mettre le citoyen en
situation de détecter la propagande et
après de l'accepter pour ce pour ce
qu'elle est
parfois il ya des aléas de la propagande
c'est non la propagande pour les vaccins
ça peut être intéressant droit en
période d'épidémie mais il faut que les
citoyens sachent que c'est de la
propagande et que à ce titre
ça peut être sujet à caution que ça peut
être remis en cause et qu' il n'y a pas
de propagande que la propagande ne
résume pas la vérité sociale ni le débat
public qu'à un moment donné elle doit se
soumettre à ottami du débat public et de
l'esprit critique
merci cécile robert dernières nouvelles
du mensonge votre nouveau livre vient de
paraître aux éditions lux merci de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]